WITH HIS SHOW, STRAIGHT AHEAD.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
IT'S BEEN MORE THAN A WEEK SINCE
A CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGY
PROFESSOR NAMED CHRISTINE FORD
ACCUSED JUDGE BRETT KAVANAUGH OF
COMMITTING SOME FORM OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT AGAINST HER BACK
IN 1982.
THEY WERE BOTH HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS OF THE TIME.
FORD'S CLAIM HAS STOPPED
CAVANAUGH'S SUPREME COURT
NOMINATION IN PLACE.
WASHINGTON HAS BEEN CONSUMED
WITH THE DEBATE EVER SINCE.
A NUMBER OF REPUBLICANS ARE SAID
TO BE UNDECIDED ON KAVANAUGH'S
GUILT OR INNOCENCE BUT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR MORE FROM
CHRISTINE FORD WHEN SHE
TESTIFIES.
STRIKINGLY THOUGH, EVERY ONE OF
THEM PLANS TO DEFEND KAVANAUGH.
AND NOW THIS WRINKLE.
NOW THESE ALLEGATIONS, AND A
LEADING DEMOCRATS CALLING THESE
NEW CLAIMS POWERFUL, COMPELLING
AND HIGHLY CREDIBLE.
THEY ARE ALL BUT DARING
REPUBLICANS TO QUESTION NEW
ACCUSERS AND THE VICTIMS THEY
SAY MUST BE BELIEVED.
HERE'S A SELECTION SELECTION OF
THE CHARGES.
>> I SAW BRIDGET BISHOP WITH THE
DEVILS.
>> I SAW SOMEBODY ELSE WITH THE
DEVIL.
>> >> Tucker: THAT'S A SCENE
FROM "THE CRUCIBLE" WHICH AS YOU
MAY REMEMBER IT WAS ARTHUR
MILLER PLAY ABOUT THE WITCH
TRIALS.
MILLER WROTE IT AS AN ALLEGORY
ABOUT THE McCARTHY HEARINGS.
McCARTHY HEARINGS WERE A
PERIOD THAT THE LEFT DEEPLY
HATED WHEN THEY TOOK POWER AND
RE-CREATED IT THEMSELVES.
NOW YOU WONDER IF PROGRESSIVES
STILL READ MILLER'S PLAY AND IF
SO, ARE THEY OUTRAGED BY IT?
IT MIGHT SEEM COMPLETELY
REASONABLE TO THEM.
BOB ACCUSES VILLAGER OF
WITCHCRAFT AND THEY DENY IT,
BECAUSE I ALWAYS DENY IT.
THE WITCH CAN'T PROVE WITHOUT A
DOUBT THAT SHE IS IN FACT A
WITCH SO TO THE STAKE SHE GOES.
CHRIS WOULD UNDERSTAND THIS
REASONING.
HE HAS BEEN MAKING THE SAME CASE
ABOUT BRETT KAVANAUGH AND PUBLIC
RECENTLY.
WATCH AND EXPLAIN IT.
>> IT IS JUDGE KAVANAUGH WHO IS
SEEKING A LIFETIME APPOINTMENT
TO THE SUPREME COURT AND I THINK
BEARS THE BURDEN OF DISPROVING
THESE ALLEGATIONS RATHER THAN
DR. FORD AND MR. RAMIREZ.
>> Tucker: SO EVEN THOSE OF
YOU THAT ARE ABSOLUTELY DEAD
CERTAIN THAT BRETT KAVANAUGH IS
GUILTY, BECAUSE YOU SAW IT ON
CNN, WOULD HAVE TO ADMIT THIS
DOES PUT HIM IN A TOUGH SPOT.
BRETT KAVANAUGH NO LONGER HAS
THAT PROTECTION SO IT'S UP TO
HIM TO CLEAR HIS OWN NAME.
HE HAS TO FIGURE OUT HOW HE CAN
PROVE THAT CHRISTINE FORD'S
FOGGY 36-YEAR-OLD MEMORIES ARE
WRONG OR HIS DAUGHTERS CANNOT
GROW UP LEARNING ABOUT HOW THEIR
DATA AS A SEX OFFENDER, THAT'S
HIS CHOICE.
AND, DEMOCRATS ARE DEMANDING
THAT KAVANAUGH CALLED DOWN YET
ANOTHER BUT DEMOCRATS WANT
ANOTHER.
THE ONLY WAY HE CAN SHOW HE'S
INNOCENT OF THESE CHARGES,
VARIOUS AND DUMB PEOPLE ON
TELEVISION AGREE WITH THIS AND
NOD THEIR HEADS IN UNISON.
BUT WHAT THAT REALLY WORK?
IS THAT THE PURPOSE OF FBI
INVESTIGATIONS?
JOE BIDEN DOESN'T THINK SO.
KEEP IN MIND THAT BIDEN IS BOTH
AN ATTORNEY AND FORMER CHAIRMAN
OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE NEXT PERSON THAT REFERS
TO AN FBI REPORT AS BEING WORTH
ANYTHING DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
ANYTHING OBVIOUSLY.
FBI EXPLICITLY DOES NOT, IN THIS
OR ANY OTHER CASE, REACH A
CONCLUSION.
PERIOD.
>> Tucker: OKAY WE FOOLED YOU
AGAIN, THAT'S JOE BIDEN FROM THE
1991 JOEL CLARENCE HEARINGS.
HE WAS ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
DEBATE THEN SO HE OBVIOUSLY HAD
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT VIEWS THAN
THE ONES HE HOLDS TODAY.
DEMOCRATS KNOW THAT OF COURSE
BUT, SO WHAT, PROVING OR
DISPROVING A RECOVERED MEMORY IS
NOT THE POINT.
THE POINT IS DESTROYING BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
MOST DEMOCRATS DON'T HATE HIM
PERSONALLY, THERE'S NOTHING
PERSONAL ABOUT ANY OF THIS.
KAVANAUGH STANDS BEHIND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE POWER
IT SEEKS.
HE'S IN THE WAY AND HE MUST BE
CRUSHED IN THE CASE OF HIS WIFE
INTO LITTLE GIRLS.
SORRY, THAT'S A COST OF WINNING.
NO OMELETTES WITHOUT SOME BROKEN
EGGS.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT OUTSIDE
PARTIES IN D.C., PEOPLE OUT
THERE DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY BELIEVE IT?
THAT'S THE ONLY OTHER THING THAT
NEVER CHANGES EVER, HUMAN
NATURE.
THERE IS A MOB INSTINCT IN
PEOPLE.
THE EVERY POPULATION, WISE
LEADERS KNOW THAT, WHY IS
LEADERS FEEL THAT.
YOU CAN TELL THE MOB IS BUILDING
BY THE WAY PEOPLE TO START
TALKING, LIKE THIS.
I THINK THERE'S A COMPROMISE
HERE COME AND HEAR ME OUT ON
THIS.
SO KAVANAUGH GETS CONFIRMED TO
THE SUPREME COURT.
OKAY, IN RETURN WE GET TO CUT
THAT PESKY OF HIS OFF IN FRONT